today's video is sponsored by light
racer the sci-fi game
made by sci-fi fans hey 42 here
picture the scene mourners are gathered
around a coffin in a church yard
they pay their respects and wander off
to the local pub for the wake
the grave is covered with earth and all
appears well as the body is laid safely
to rest
but just hours later under cover of
darkness
and perhaps whilst the last few mourners
are reminiscing
over one last pint several men emerged
from the shadows
and dig the body out of its grave they
work
quickly to rebury the empty coffin and
cover it back up with earth
over the coming weeks months and years
relatives who come to lay flowers and
pay their respects
never realize that person is no longer
there
sounds pretty horrific but once upon a
time
that happened on a daily basis
light racer is a sci-fi game that gives
you the power
to determine the fate of entire
civilizations
based around the big rip hypothesis
in which the universe is slowly being
torn apart
due to its own expansion you play as the
navigator
of a high-tech arc together with your
best companion
an ai bot the game tells the story of
various planets and civilizations
struggling to survive at the twilight of
the universe
and you are required to decide whether
to help them rise
or fall however choose carefully as
every decision you make within the game
has an impact
on the ending also make sure you look
out for the star
childs every planet gives you the
opportunity to collect one
each star child you collect will unlock
more of the story light racer is created
by a dev team of only four people
who have a real passion for science
fiction and that really comes across
because
the game is full of subtle references to
sci-fi classics
such as hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
the matrix
and the movie arrival this serious
dedication to sci-fi
is my favorite thing about light racer
and it's just a fantastically fun game
to play
light racer is available worldwide and
you can download it for free
and start playing today by clicking the
link in the description below
find out where your choices will take
you
share your version of the story in the
comments below
and let me know if you successfully
collect all the star children
check it out in early 19th century
britain
freshly buried bodies were regularly dug
up and transported away to a mysterious
location
why was victorian britain rife with
necrophiliacs
probably but that wasn't their intended
purpose for these particular stolen
corpses
no these specimens were sold on to
medical students
who needed a constant supply of cadavers
for dissection
and without modern embalming methods the
specimens needed to be very fresh
previously this hadn't been much of an
issue as the bodies of executed
criminals
were sent straight to medical schools
dissection was
simply another part of the punishment
in 1751 the government passed a murder
act
which dictated that the bodies of
executed murderers
must be made available to medical
science
remember this was a society that still
crowded in town squares
to watch the occasional hanging nobody
is going to be bothered about the body
of a killer being
chopped up a little bit criminals
sentenced to death would sometimes be
more frightened
of the idea of being dissected than
being
executed records from newgate prison
london's largest and most notorious
reveal the fear felt by one very young
assailant
john amy bird bell convicted of murder
and sentenced to death in 1831
at the age of just 14 was said to have
shown no fear of death
at all when he was sentenced but
when he was told that he would be
dissected after death
he broke down in court at the turn of
the 19th century medical science was
advancing fast
with a flurry of medical schools being
built along with anatomical theatres
where students would pack into viewing
galleries to watch a dissection
you can still visit one of these the old
operating theatre in southwark
founded in 1822 though it's now a museum
damn it i miss my chance in its
dissection days
the floor was covered in sawdust to
prevent bodily fluids seeping through
the floorboards
into the church below at least that
would have given the passion of jesus
sermon
that real 4d experience anatomical
theatres lined with rows of eager
medical students
relied on a regular supply of bodies the
problem was
the number of people being executed was
falling
around 60 a year were executed in
england between 1800
and 1835 half the number seen
in the 18th century then in 1823
the medical schools hit yet another
supply chain issue
there had been 220 crimes that carried a
death sentence in
england and wales including stealing
anything worth more than 12 pence
this meant that death sentences were
handed out for stealing a loaf of bread
or picking a pocket the 1823 judgement
of death act
changed all this allowing judges to
choose
a lesser sentence often transportation
to a penal colony
instead this was good news for britain's
numerous poor
who frequently had to resort to stealing
in order to eat
but it was terrible news for anatomists
and medical students
there just weren't enough people being
executed
enter the body snatchers
to meet the ever-growing demand a
roaring cadaver trade emerged
mostly operating in gangs body snatchers
would hang around graveyards
wait until dark and then dig up a grave
some would even target houses where they
knew there had been a recent death in
the family
and break in to steal the body pretty
grim
i know but body snatching
was well rewarded a laborer in early
19th century london
might earn around 15 pounds a year a
body sold to a medical school
might fetch anything from 2 to 20 pounds
and it really was a roaring trade
an 1828 parliamentary select committee
examining the issue of body snatching
found
that 592 bodies had been dissected in
medical schools
in 1826 around 10 times
the number of executions
surprisingly body snatching wasn't
technically illegal as bodies
were not legally considered to be
property
in 1822 a man named william millard
was arrested whilst attempting a body
snatch in the grounds of royal london
hospital
he couldn't be arrested for stealing the
body because it wasn't illegal
so he was arrested for the spurious
charge of vagrancy
instead but millard protested his
innocence
not only had he previously worked for
the hospital
he told the police he had an arrangement
with them for 12 years
when a patient's body was buried he
would be asked to
simply head down into the hospital's
graveyard and dig it back up again
well then what was the bloody point in
burying it in the first place
but it's suspected that usually royal
london
didn't even bother to bury a body before
they sent it on to an anatomy theater
archaeologists working in the hospital's
grounds in 2006
found something unexpected
[Music]
not neatly placed skeletons that had
been buried
whole in the usual manner but
jumbles of bones mixed up and buried
together
these included skulls with the tops
sliced off
bones that had been dissected and animal
bones from dogs and tortoises
there were bodies missing skulls and
others missing hands and feet
across 262 burials
they estimated there were the remains of
around 500
different people
[Music]
by piecing together records stretching
from 1820
to 1850 researchers worked out
where all these bodies had come from
people
would die in the hospital's wards be
taken to the adjoining
medical school for the section and
afterwards
their remains were simply chucked into
unmarked graves
in this unofficial secret graveyard
but how did the hospital decide whose
body went on to the medical school and
who was to be buried normally
well this east end hospital was close to
london's docks
so they were supplied with a steady
stream of patients
who'd picked up one of the many diseases
that regularly ravaged
19th century sailors or had otherwise
suffered a fatal injury
whilst on board these were generally
young
strong men in the prime of their lives
perfect dissection material
and usually no one in london would be
looking for them
but it's thought that the majority of
bodies that ended up on medical school
dissection tables
got there via body snatchers to protect
themselves from the snatchers inevitable
invasion
people began to take increasingly
ingenious measures
watchtowers were hastily built in
graveyards across the country
to look out for body snatchers families
of the recently deceased would protect
graves with cages or
gates some had locked iron coffins that
were
almost impossible to open those who
couldn't afford such measures
would cover their relatives graves with
stones
rather than soil in a desperate attempt
to dissuade
the snatchers in 1828 it was thought
that there were around
200 body snatchers working in london
in gangs of four or five but even with
200 men regularly digging up bodies
and many more in other british cities
they still couldn't meet
the endless demand this meant that
gravesnatching
quickly turned to murder rather than
stealing the bodies of already dead
people
the body snatchers started to make dead
the most famous of these were william
burke and william hare
who went about their gruesome trade in
edinburgh
supplying the edinburgh university
medical school
with bodies as and when needed
both men had left northern ireland to
work as labourers on the union canal
where they met became friends and ended
up living on the same street
both settled down with a partner and
each couple would regularly take in
lodges
when in 1827 one of the long-term
tenants of william hare's house
died owing rent the two friends decided
they would sell his body to the medical
school
to get some of that money back and they
made a profit
the rent owed was just four pounds and
they were paid
seven pounds and ten shillings for the
body by robert
knox the medical school's anatomist
that's around 900 pounds in today's
money not bad for a side hustle
book and hair could smell the business
opportunity right in front of them
in 1828 an unfortunate tenant
named joseph became very ill while
staying
in hare's house but they didn't fancy
popping the kettle on and patiently
waiting for him to die they gave joseph
a helping hand after encouraging the
poor boy to drink more whiskey than was
probably advisable
they restrained and suffocated him with
their bare hands
this method of killing became burke and
hare's
modus operandi and it was later given a
catchy title
burking and whilst
burke and hare had perhaps justified the
burking of
joseph on the basis that he was already
ill and likely to die anyway there was
no such
dubious moral code attached to their
later killings
they began actively encouraging people
to stay with them
with full intentions to give them a good
burking
they are reported to have murdered 16
people
and made at least 15 000 pounds
from the cadavers though these official
figures
are likely to be a drop in the bloody
bucket
without any obvious injuries burked
bodies were perfectly fresh and easily
sellable
whilst robert knox the anatomist later
denied all knowledge of the origins of
the bodies he purchased from burke and
hare
a man of his profession would certainly
have known
that these weren't dug up weak old
bodies
but burke and her soon came unstuck
and their last victim was a woman named
marjorie dougherty
he was suitably murdered on halloween
night
in 1828 she was invited to stay with
burke
and was in fact a distant relative of
his but
burke had other lodges at the time a
couple named
james and ann gray even though their
method of
suffocation wasn't outwardly injurious
to the victims
it wasn't necessarily quiet
and so burke sent the couple to stay at
hare's house
whilst they got busy killing margaery
when the couple returns the next day the
greys asked where marjorie had gone
they were told she'd been asked to leave
because she was flirting with burke
but when they asked to enter the room
where marjorie had been killed to
collect their belongings
they were told they couldn't if they
weren't suspicious already
i'm sure they were by now when they were
finally allowed in
they found marjorie's lifeless body
hidden
underneath the bed they were offered a
significant bribe
of 10 pounds around 1700 pounds in
today's money
a week to keep quiet presumably burke
and her plans to
simply kill an extra person a week to
fund the bribe
but unwilling to retire on the proceeds
of crime
the couple hot-footed it to the nearest
police station
and burke hair and their partners
were all arrested and questioned
it didn't take long for the accomplices
to turn against each other
the police knew they didn't have strong
enough evidence to convict
and so they convinced her to turn
state's evidence
he confessed to 16 murders including
marjories
and gave evidence against burke in
return for immunity
against prosecution burke was convicted
of murder
and hanged in front of a crowd of 25
000 people in january 1829
ironically his body was donated to
medical science
and his skeleton can still be seen in
surgeons hall
in edinburgh it's said that some of the
students who worked on his body
took strips of his skin as souvenirs
beats a fridge magnet if you ask me
after burke was hanged hare was released
from prison
he had become a notorious figure whose
face would have been highly recognizable
by now
so he left edinburgh on a male coach
chances are if he tried to walk he
wouldn't have reached a city border
without being attacked by an angry mob
in fact he only made it as far as
dumfries before he was recognized
and attacked by said angry mob he
escaped
though we don't know where to one story
is that he ended up in liverpool
hospital
several years later where he was
recognized and killed by a fellow
patient
another is that he was blinded by an
angry mob who threw
quick lime in his face and he ended up
begging on the streets of london
whatever happened to him it's safe to
say he wasn't britain's most popular man
burke and hare's body snatching career
may have been short but it did provide
inspiration to other body snatchers
most notably a gang who became known as
the london burkas for a long time they
successfully stole
and sold bodies to several hospitals
including saint bartz and saint thomas's
one of the men
john bishop would later admit to
stealing a staggering 1000
bodies but that's just bragging if you
ask me
like others before them stealing bodies
proved a gateway crime
and soon they were luring people to
their untimely deaths
they would find people sleeping rough on
the streets
promised them a place to stay and then
once out of sight drug and kill them
they rented two small cottages in an
undesirable area prone to flooding
in order to carry out their crimes
the gang was discovered in 1831 when
they tried to sell the body of a 14 year
old boy
named charles ferrari to king's college
hospital
they of course told the anatomist that
he died of natural causes
but when he inspected the corpse he
found a swollen
cut face bloodshot eyes and what was
clearly
a very fresh body as this particular
anatomist clearly had more scruples than
edinburgh's robert knox he reported the
gang to the police
and three members john bishop james may
and thomas williams were arrested
when police searched their rented
cottages
they found the clothes of multiple
victims discarded
in the well and outside toilet
the free men were tried at the old
bailey with their trial causing a media
sensation
all three were found guilty two of them
williams and bishop were sentenced to
death hanged in front of 30 000
people and their bodies of course
donated to medical science for
dissection
mate was transported to tasmania where
he died in 1834
the trials of both the burqas and
burkhand
were the catalysts for the passing of
the anatomy act
of 1832 this act made
bodies legal property for the first time
and required anatomists to have a
license to possess them
that license gave them legal access to
the bodies of people who died in prisons
workhouses and hospitals and were
unclaimed by relatives
relatives could also choose to donate a
body in return for funeral expenses
conveniently this also meant that the
local authorities
didn't have to pay funeral costs for
paupers in their care
the act put an end to the body snatchers
trade as medical schools then had ready
access to a stream of bodies
that's supply and demand for you though
it's fair to say
it wasn't popular with everyone and was
widely criticized for targeting the poor
unsurprisingly britain's wealthy failed
to come forward to
donate their bodies and the act remained
in force
until 1984.
[Music]
thanks for watching